U
BACK HERE TOMORROW NIGHT.
♪ ♪
>> Laura: I'M LAURA INGRAHAM,
THIS IS "THE INGRAHAM ANGLE"
FROM WASHINGTON TONIGHT, THANKS
FOR BEING WITH US.
THE REAL TERRORISTS, THAT'S THE
FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S "ANGLE."
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE THEIR
NARRATIVES SET, LONG BEFORE
BIDEN WAS SWORN INTO OFFICE.
THERE IS WASN'T A STORY ABOUT
HOW AMERICANS WOULD THRIVE OR BE
SAFE AND HAPPY UNDER THE BIDEN
POLICIES.
BECAUSE THEIR CLIMATE CHANGE OF
SESSION WOULD DEEPLY DAMAGE
AMERICAN FAMILIES.
THEY ALWAYS KNEW THAT.
THEREFORE, AS KIND OF A
PREEMPTIVE MEASURE, THEY DECIDED
TO ARGUE THE NEGATIVE, THAT
ELECTING REPUBLICANS IN THE
FUTURE WOULD BE AKIN TO ELECTING
TERRORISTS WHO WOULD SEEK TO
BLOW UP OUR ENTIRE SYSTEM.
>> THIS IS JUST AN EXTRA
ORDINARILY DANGEROUS COURSE FOR
REPUBLICANS TO BE TAKING IN
TERMS OF OUR DEMOCRACY.
>> THE REPUBLICAN PARTY CAN NO
LONGER SAY THEY DON'T AGREE WITH
THE INSURRECTIONIST, THE BIGOTS,
THE RACISTS.
>> THERE MAY NOW BE PEOPLE
ALIGNED WITH WHAT'S A PREMISES
OR IN CONGRESS.
HOW YOU PROTECT THE COUNTRY FROM
THEM?
>> IT COULD BE THAT WE HAVE A
REPUBLICAN MAJORITY IN CONGRESS
THIS FALL, AND IF THAT HAPPENS,
YOU MAY SEE REPUBLICANS IN
CONGRESS WANTING TO CUT THE
MONEY TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE TO TURN THE LIGHTS OUT.
WE MAY LOSE OUR DEMOCRACY.
>> Laura: THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
ISSUED OMINOUS WARNINGS.
>> THE TOP DOMESTIC THREAT COMES
FROM RACIALLY OR ETHNICALLY
MOTIVATED VIOLENCE, EXTREMIST,
SPECIFICALLY THOSE WHO ADVOCATE
FOR THE SUPERIORITY OF THE WHITE
RACE.
>> Laura: THEY ANNOUNCED NEW
TASK FORCES.
>> I DECIDED TO ESTABLISH A
DOMESTIC TERRORISM UNIT TO
AUGMENT OUR EXISTING APPROACH.
IF THIS GROUP OF DEDICATED
ATTORNEYS WILL FOCUS ON THE
DOMESTIC TERRORISM THREAT.
>> Laura: AND OF COURSE
ESPECIALLY AFTER JANUARY 6, THE
MEDIA NEVER LOOKED BACK.
SO CHICAGO COULD REMAIN A
KILLING FIELD, A HUNDRED
THOUSAND AMERICAN'S COULD DIE
FROM OVERDOSES, CHINA COULD PLOT
AGAINST US IN THE ASIAN-PACIFIC
AND INSTEAD OF COVERING ANY OF
THAT AS IT NEEDS TO BE COVERED,
THE PRESS FOCUSED ALMOST
SINGULARLY ON VILIFYING THE
CONSERVATIVE MOVEMENT WITH
GROUNDLESS SMEARS ABOUT AN
INSURRECTION THAT WASN'T.
AND WITH THE WHEELS COMING OFF
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY BECAUSE,
YOU KNOW, LOOK, BECAUSE OF OUR
CRUMBLING ECONOMY, JANUARY 6TH
MESS IS STILL ALL THEY'VE GOT.
>> THIS WEEK'S HEARING, THE
JANUARY 6TH HEARING, WHICH
SURELY ARE THE MOST IMPORTANT
HEARINGS SINCE WATERGATE.
>> HEARINGS ARE GOING TO BE
QUITE COMPELLING.
I THINK THEY UNDERSTAND THE
IMPORTANCE OF LEVERAGING LIVE
TELEVISION TO CONVINCE THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC HOW SERIOUS THIS
WAS.
>> WE HAVE THIS COMMITTEE
INVESTIGATION COMING UP, WHICH
AGAIN, IF YOU REALLY LOVE
AMERICA, IF YOU BELIEVE IN
AMERICAN DEMOCRACY, PURE
PATRIOT, YOU WANT TO KNOW WHAT
HAPPENED ON JANUARY 6TH.
>> Laura: OH, JOE, TELL US
ABOUT IT.
FIRST OFF, ON ITS FACE THESE
ALLEGATIONS ARE LUDICROUS.
THE IDEA THAT RAGTAG GROUP OF
PEOPLE WHO SMASH THEIR WAY INTO
THE CAPITAL, THAT THEY WERE THE
PRODUCT OF SOME ORGANIZED EFFORT
ORCHESTRATED OUT OF THE
WEST WING, IT'S BEYOND
RIDICULOUS.
IF THERE WAS TRUE EVIDENCE OF
ANY OF THAT, WE HAVE ALREADY
HEARD ABOUT IT.
THE MOMENT I SAW WHAT WAS
HAPPENING TO CAPITOL HILL I
TEXTED MARK MEADOWS, THE CHIEF
OF STAFF OF THE WHITE HOUSE,
TOLD HIM TO ASK THE PRESIDENT TO
SHOW EVERYONE TO GO HOME, I
THINK I WAS THE FIRST PERSON TO
DO THAT, MAYBE ONE OF THE FIRST.
I KNEW IT WAS GOING TO HURT THE
CAUSE AND I SAID THE SAME THING
PUBLICLY ON TWITTER THROUGHOUT
THE AFTERNOON AND THAT MIGHT ON
THE ANGLE.
IT WAS OBVIOUS A GROUP OF ANGRY
PEOPLE HAD WHIPPED UP THE CROWD
INTO A FRENZY AND THAT'S WHEN
THINGS BECAME VIOLENT.
WE'VE ALWAYS SAID IN MANY CASE
WHEN LAWS ARE BROKEN,
PERPETRATORS NEED TO BE
PUNISHED, JUSTICE MUST BE DONE
WITHOUT REGARD TO POLITICS.
BUT THAT WASN'T ENOUGH FOR THE
DEMOCRATS.
THEY HAVE ATTEMPTED,
UNSUCCESSFULLY, TO USE
JANUARY 6TH TO INDICT THE ENTIRE
REPUBLICAN PARTY AND PROTECT
THEMSELVES.
IN OTHER WORDS, TO INSULATE
THEMSELVES FROM ANY
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THE
DEVASTATION THEY ARE CURRENTLY
WREAKING UPON AMERICA.
INDEED, IT IS THE DEMOCRATS AND
THEIR FAR LEFT FAITH THAT ARE
THE ONES THAT HAVE BEEN
TERRORIZING AMERICA THESE PAST
FEW YEARS.
WE ARE NEVER GOING TO FORGET THE
WILD THINGS THAT MASQUERADED AS
PROTESTS.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Laura: CAN YOU BELIEVE THAT
WAS AMERICA?
AND OF COURSE ANTIFA CITIZEN
JOURNALISTS.
>> WHAT THE [BLEEP]!
[BLEEP] [BLEEP]!
>> Laura: THEN THERE WAS BLM
HARASSING INNOCENT AMERICANS.
>> NO JUSTICE!
NO PEACE!
>> Laura: ABORTION FANATICS
BESIEGING THE HOMES OF
SUPREME COURT JUSTICES.
>> Laura: SHOWING UP AT JILL
O'STEEN'S LAKEWOOD CHURCH IN
TEXAS.
>> IT'S MY BODY, MY CHOICE!
IF MY BODY, MY CHOICE!
OVERTURNED BEFORE!
>> Laura: IF THAT I THAT
UNDERWEAR WASN'T ENOUGH TO
TERRIFY YOU, THEY ARE UPPING THE
ANTE BY VANDALIZING FOR CRISIS
PREGNANCY CENTERS AROUND THE
COUNTRY.
IT STARTED ABOUT A MONTH AGO IN
MADISON, WISCONSIN.
>> WE ARE INVESTIGATING THE
FRUITS OF HATE AND VIOLENCE IN
THE FORM OF AN ARSON WHERE A
SPECIFIC NONPROFIT GROUP WAS
TARGETED FOR THEIR BELIEFS
REGARDING THE ISSUE OF ABORTION.
>> Laura: AND IT CONTINUES TO
THIS DAY.
THIS PAST WEEKEND, A PREGNANCY
CRISIS CENTER IN
WASHINGTON, D.C.,'S CAPITOL HILL
NEIGHBORHOOD WAS VANDALIZED WITH
RED PAINT, EGGS, AND A MESSAGE
READING "JANE SAYS REVENGE."
IN AMHERST NEW YORK YESTERDAY,
MORE ACTS OF TERROR.
CONFERENCE SEEK -- WINDOWS
BROKEN, IT WAS GRAFFITI THEN SET
ON FIRE.
POLICE INVESTIGATING IT AS
ARSON.
>> JAMES REVENGE IS A GROUP THAT
IS ATTEMPTING TO STRIKE FEAR
INTO THE HEARTS OF PRO-LIFE
SERVICE ORGANIZATIONS TO KEEP
THEM FROM PROVIDING CARE.
THE INTENT WAS FOR COMPASS CARE
TO STOP SERVICES.
WE WON'T STOP BURIED
>> Laura: WHEN POLICE OFFICERS
CALLED MY NEXT GUEST, CHRISSY
BROWN, THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
MOUNTAINEER PREGNANCY SERVICES
TO TELL HER THAT THE CLINIC SHE
RUNS HAVE BEEN VANDALIZED, THEY
WARNED HER THAT IT WAS BAD.
WHEN SHE GOT TO THE DOOR FOR
CLINIC THIS MORNING, SHE FOUND
THREATENING MESSAGES SPRAYED IN
RED PAINT ON THREE SIDES OF THE
BUILDING AND THE SIDEWALK AS
WELL WAS BROKEN WITH WINDOWS,
PAINTED ON THE PROPERTY WHERE
THE MESSAGES "IF ABORTIONS
AREN'T SAFE, NEITHER ARE YOU."
WE WILL SHOW THAT PICTURE IN A
MOMENT.
UNDERSTAND, THESE HOMES ARE
OFTEN RUN BY VOLUNTEERS -- MOST
OF THEM ARE -- WHO SELFLESSLY
TRY TO ASSIST UNWED, OFTENTIMES
SCARED, EXPECTANT MOTHERS.
THESE CRISIS PREGNANCY CENTERS
OFFER YOUNG WOMEN HOPE AND
COMPASSION WHEN THEY NEED IT
MOST.
THINK OF HOW SICK THOSE ARE WHO
THREATEN THE SANCTUARY.
HOW IS ANY OF THIS NOT A
HATE CRIME?
WHERE THE CONGRESSIONAL
HEARINGS?
THE CAPITOL HILL PRESS
CONFERENCES CONDEMNING THE HATE
GROUPS BEHIND THESE THOUGHTS?
WE KNOW THE ANSWER.
IF YOU'RE PRO-LIFE, DEMOCRATS
REALLY DON'T THINK YOU DESERVE
TO BE PROTECTED FROM HATE.
IN FACT, YOU DESERVE HATE.
ONCE AGAIN, THE DEMOCRATS HAVE
GONE SO FAR LEFT THAT LEFT
AMERICA.
NONE OF THIS IS GOING TO BREAK
THROUGH, I DON'T THINK, OR MAKE
THE SLIGHTEST DIFFERENCE IN
NOVEMBER.
MOST REGULAR PEOPLE -- I DON'T
KNOW, I'M GETTING THE SENSE THAT
THEY SEE JANUARY 6TH AS AN AWFUL
ABERRATION, NOT AS THE EVENT
THAT DEFINES AMERICA OR THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
DEMOCRATS AND THEIR MEDIA
MINIONS, THEY ARE GOING FULL
STEAM AHEAD.
THEY'RE HOPING FOR A RUNAWAY
SUMMER BLOCKBUSTER, THE
DEFINITION OF OUT OF TOUCH
SHOULD INCLUDE BLOWING COUNTLESS
MILLIONS OF TAXPAYER DOLLARS ON
PARTISAN HEARINGS ONE AMERICAN
MOMS STILL CAN'T FIND BABY
FORMULA.
SO THE REAL TERRORISTS ARE THOSE
SEEKING TO OVERTHROW EVERY
AMERICAN TRADITION FROM THE
APOLITICAL NATURE OF THE
SUPREME COURT TO THE SANCTITY OF
CHURCHES, AND THEY ARE NOT DOING
IT THROUGH DEMOCRATIC PROCESSES,
BUT THROUGH INTIMID